[Music]
so at first when star trek discovery
started i'm like spore drive
right okay and then like say their their
technology was just like tng sort of
levels or even beyond and i'm still like
this doesn't make sense
like it's like
why do you keep doing prequels we don't
care
and it's like
you know
it's it's where do you say this because
my mike and i were discussing this and
we were saying you know if you want to
have technology
that is beyond that appropriate period
just said it later i mean it made it
other than other than the spock and
sarrick reference
what difference did it make time wise
they have that they could have had a
second klingon more i mean they had that
in the freaking i don't know if either
of you guys played star trek online
yeah a little bit yeah there was a there
was a second klingon war so why not just
said it then if if you want to change
the law you know and i i know but it's
nitpicky but we're freaking star trek
fans like we're gonna be nitpicky that's
star trek that's what we do
it's like the thing that annoyed me was
though it complicates your life as the
writer because again like you said the
two things that star trek proper
trekkies have got is that we really
nitpick over the canon
and we like that we like the story to
actually have a you know flow with
detail orientated and we like the ships
and the technology
so why do a prequel that just
complicates all of that you can't just
do whatever you want in the series i
mean that's why they did the kelvin
timeline wasn't it because they thought
we'll just create this event we can
change time we can that's this is a new
universe now so we can do whatever we
want sort of thing
um and that's how they got around it
discovery didn't do that they just made
their lives harder so just don't just
set it just after tng ended
you know
exactly well exactly i mean the last we
saw was freaking uh nemesis which was a
wasn't a big idea
i like them do you like what you like
nemesis yeah yeah i like the space i
like the summertime
i liked um i liked
surprisingly i liked interaction i
thought interaction was pretty good i
saw it in the cinema when i was about
seven i loved it um
it's got a new it's got an evil admiral
it's it's a
theater when i was seven
i was at the theater when i was 27.
you know
amy come on insurrection is awful
it's all seen no it's everything you're
just wrong expense um
and now i know why i'm in the middle
yeah exactly
i'm kind of ashamed that we've gotten to
this point we haven't uh mentioned
lowered x
okay
the thing i love about lower decks is
that it is a bouquet of easter eggs
oh my god it is got i mean it's you have
to watch every episode four or five
times to catch all the damn easter eggs
you just whoever wrote it
is just a complete trekkie you just
loved tmg as well every time you watch
it you just go oh my god i know what
they're running about i know i know the
inside joke on that one certainly it
looks like i mean it i mean i you know
is yes meant for a younger audience but
i mean it is the the the scripts are
cherry picked for the nerdiest of the
nerds
but
but stormy as you've just very much
identified yes for a younger audience
but at the same time they've managed to
do the pixar thing which is where it's
aimed for a younger audience but it also
has things appeal to an older audience
and and i actually i was i was going to
come to this way later but
i personally feel the lower decks
for me was was more of an authentic star
trek series than picard was or um
discovery season two
are we allowed to talk spoilers are we
being spoilery yeah you know if you
haven't watched it why are you watching
the the end of um lower deck season one
it blew my mind when the bajoran
security officer got killed and why got
the thing ripped out i was like that i
felt more emotionally moved by that
after a couple of episodes than i did at
the end of um season two of discovery
like i cared so much more about those
characters even though the comedy
element was there and it was cartoony
like i felt like they established
everybody more and maybe that's through
episodic um episode i don't know but i
it had so much more of an impact for me
yeah i don't know about you it is a
comedy it is a kids show
but the thing is it works and
like
it's the easter eggs isn't it
i love the thing where she's um
she's getting drunk on the romulan nail
instead
you think it'd be green but actually
it's blue and it's freaking awesome look
i got a backlit
it's just it's just silly
we're watching it go with this yeah it's
that that's the thing for me it's
authentic star trek and you've seen
about star trek's lost identity
watch picard
and then watch lower decks
which is which is star trek
it's not freaking picard
the federation aren't even in picard
except that he goes to the office once
which looks suspiciously like a bank
the federation isn't in picard and it
raises a lot of
questions yeah it looks lighter
but those are my main problems with
picard other than the fact
the end was terrible
and those starships we see at the end
the shanghi and all those
are just bad
and apparently it was all thrown in
really last minute apparently the
creators are just like we've made picard
we have the federation aren't in it so
we maybe put the federation in it
and it was like a week before
post-production was supposed to end so
they threw it together and you can tell
the the thing i loved about picard
was the stories that had nothing to do
with him
it was
mine you know joining you know coming up
with the rangers and all that i thought
that was a strong storyline and please
ward somebody make a series out of that
that was much more interesting than the
whole you know
um
i thought and and also
um
at least riker's got a ship now i mean
for god's sake i mean that was
interesting orientation but the thing i
liked the most he seems to have stolen a
ship i just want i think he beamed
aboard that ship like this one or
shanghai whatever it's called
which would have had a captain
yeah so
i'm uh bye
and the country's like what
start off mate i've this is my ship now
and i'm taking the fleet with me
and then and the fleet that's weirdly
exactly the same so we've got hundreds
of ships
bye
and the country's like what
sort of mate i've this is my ship now
and i'm taking the fleet with me
and then and the fleet that's weirdly
exactly the same so we've got hundreds
of ships
i've got i've got so much to say about
that later jay so much to say
one of the impulse engines just fell off
one of the ships as well the the the
other thing i liked about the uh
discovery was a similar kind of thing
season two of discovery my favorite
thing was uh the stories are the
background with pike
you